good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a Thursday that
I totally thought was a Wednesday when I
woke up with a migraine this morning I
was so confused I had no way to know
what day it was I had to check my phone
and we are here it is very rainy and
stormy in New York City it's a stormy
Webster kind of day but those are the
best days in the queue hey Claude what's
good hey guys welcome to the morning
toast I'm Claudia I am back on a normal
sleep schedule and I have never felt
more alive like I was in bed 12:30 up
9:30 like how normal I that's very
normal a good nine hours yeah and like
not crazy hours just like standard like
when people go to sleep I just feel so
human I'm only human and I bleed when I
fall down that's that's really great I'm
happy for you this was just not my day
so far this episode is gonna be a little
late for people cuz I woke up with a
migraine and I just couldn't but I'm
feeling a little better so we're here
but now I'm like ran out of my medicine
so like I'm gonna have to go out in this
storm and get more man your magic pills
my magic pills I need them um I hate to
you know change the subject so quickly
but can we just address the sweatshirt
that you're wearing oh yes it's actually
a vintage relic at this point it's like
it's a cultural relic
it is a sweatshirt it's a sweatshirt
from Kyle Richards former show on
Paramount called American women woman
about her mom and her life growing up we
were at a screening and we got these
sweatshirts and they're honestly so
comfortable and that's when they said
yesterday that I was looking for my zip
up so I legit have four sweaters with a
zip two of them are the American woman
and two of them are from surf Lodge and
I'm just in like a zip up kind of mood
we are both like rocking such culturally
important sweatshirts because I'm
wearing a wild fox sweatshirt that
Taylor Swift also has and she wore the
matching pants in the Miss America on
the documentary so like we are just two
women supporting women oh for sure this
show is actually pretty good American
woman I don't know why it got canned
yeah it got sacked almost immediately
and I love her and we're gonna
so much about Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills but cut like you know how you have
that guy who's in every TV show that you
like that always ends up getting
canceled that's like Kyle Richards none
of her TV projects had really ever take
off
yeah but they feel like for American
woman like the problem was it was on
paramount Network and like nothing
really hit there even one of those
something so crazy waco was originally
on paramount network that's where it
premiered and that's why we never
[ __ ] heard of it
yeah because paramount Network went
through like a weird rebrand because
they were Spike TV which was like a
weird channel but it had its like niche
audience with like people who ride
motorcycles and then they decided to do
like a totally random rebrand into like
Paramount which was like this you know
cinematographers dream network and they
were like trying so hard to be like
Hollywood vibe and it just didn't work
out but I think that's the channel that
um Chrissy Teigen lipstick battle is on
ya know they actually do like premium
content but I guess not enough people
get the channel in order to watch the
shows and that's possible I don't know
if I get it I don't know if I get it
either but anyway it's a grateful for
this but you're grateful for Waco and
yeah Real Housewives of Beverly Hills is
kind of the only reason I got up this
morning like otherwise this episode is
there's not like so much we need to talk
about the celebs are taking a day off
yeah a lot of Hadean it'll be a nice
quick little episode today but if you're
looking for more content or less episode
of the month of April for our patreon
channel went up I did a podcast episode
with Ben it was so funny we were
literally fighting the whole time
but like any cute funny way like not in
a problematic way I hope not so it's on
the patreon channel patreon.com/scishow
morning toast and when you sign up it's
nine dollars a month but when you sign
up you get access to all the past
episodes so it's almost like 200
episodes now so perfect for quarantine
there's videos there's podcasts
patreon.com slash good morning toast
love it okay before we get into anything
else we have a major update for you guys
regarding cam toast 2020 we said that we
were gonna wait until May to make a
decision and may begin tomorrow so we've
made our decision and unfortunately we
have to postpone camp toast it doesn't
make any sense for us to do it Memorial
Day weekend that is like very eager of
us to think that we could so we are
moving camp toast to September the
weekend of September 10th to the 13th it
will start on a Thursday evening and end
on a Sunday because there's no
like we don't have a long weekend that
we can do it on so it'll start on the
Thursday evening and on the Sunday
September 10th to the 13th we are going
to postpone it in Eventbrite if you
already have a ticket and you want to
keep your ticket great you don't have to
do anything if you can no longer go this
weekend in September you can get a
refund for your ticket your spot will
open up other toasters can come instead
so we will have all the information for
you in the groups on Instagram or be
taking your questions you can always
email us but that is the official word
I'm cam toes 2020 so it's still
happening just in like four months yeah
we know there was a lot of concern about
the event being canceled and we did not
want to do that so hopefully
everything's good by September like if
she isn't good by September like where I
get if she doesn't go by September like
we have much bigger problems than cam
toast I think will be will be totally
fine yeah I I'm very optimistic that it
will be great I'm looking forward to
like a nice fall weekend in the Poconos
with the toasters and it's like a great
way to celebrate everything that this
year has brought yes so don't worry if
you can't make it we will see you next
year and you way you are entitled to a
full refund and if you weren't able to
come for one reason or another you got a
wedding or something maybe now you can
come so it's all good yeah it's all good
it's gonna be really fun and I feel like
by September I mean hopefully we'll be
out of the keel on May 15th and things
will slowly be getting back to normal
but by September like we'll be able to
go balls to the walls all toasters on
deck it's gonna be craziness it's gonna
be the celebration we've been waiting
for like the block party that we've been
talking about so I'm now even more
excited about it it's gonna be ready
guys so stay tuned and thanks for being
patient with us yes okay so I think
without time it's without further ado
it's time to get into the first five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay first up the big news
of the week even though Kristin
Cavallari and J color thought it was
gonna be them
it is Gigi Hadid and Zayn Malik's little
bit and even though they did not confirm
it themselves Yolanda has confirmed the
news so that's as much of a confirmation
as we're ever gonna get Yolanda Hadid
has confirmed that her supermodel
daughter
gigi hadid is pregnant the dutch born
former Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
star said the recent rumors are true
that Gigi 25 and boyfriend Zayn Malik 27
are expecting their first child sharing
the news with Dutch TV program RTL
Boulevard she said quote still shocked
our little secret got leaked to the
press
of course we are so excited Yolanda said
heard the outlets Instagram posts from
Wednesday
quote I'm excited to become OMA in
September especially after I lost my mom
so recently but this is the beauty of
life one soul leaves us and a new one
comes in we feel very blessed
also TMZ has reported that Gigi and Zayn
are expecting a girl I just like I just
I still I can't and refuse to believe
that this is true like I know you'll
want to confirmed it and like that's to
be honest like even when I was posting
on our Instagram that they were pregnant
they were expecting a girl part of me
thought that this whole thing was like
gonna end up not being true but Yolanda
confirming it is actual confirmation and
I just can't believe it like to me it's
so crazy yeah it's so crazy you know
what I just realized yesterday like
eight after this after we recorded the
toast and talked about it
I remember that Gigi was dating Tyler
Cameron like I completely forgot about
that oh wait did you see like Tyler
Cameron confirmed speculation that he is
not the father of gigi hadid baby like
nobody [ __ ] thought that yeah except
she is due in September like probably
around the time of camp toast 2020 um
which means I can't really do math on
the spot right now cuz my head hurts but
me she's kind of far along she's five
months along 20 weeks Wow ya know if she
honestly kept it a secret for like a
good amount of time I mean nobody is as
iconic or as prolific as Kylie keeping
her entire thing prep pregnancy a secret
and there was like speculation but
honestly I did not think she was
actually pregnant until the day the baby
came out of her vagina so like who knows
Tara but Gigi did what she could five
months is a lot for like a major
celebrity to major celebrities yeah I
totally agree
so that's so exciting I just like when I
was thinking about Gigi and Zayn how
their OTP they've always dated other
people but they come back to each other
like I completely forgot about the part
where she was dating tyler cameron and
she like took the world by storm
the craziest thing somebody's ever done
it's been a crazy year for obviously I
think her dating Tyler Cameron is
crazier than her being pregnant right
now with things that I I think they're
both actually equally as crazy um she
know what it is it's like the Tyler
thing was so crazy but it wasn't
unbelievable like part of this is just
so not believable to me I don't know why
I'm the complete opposite like the Tyler
thing was unbelievable to me this is
like oh my gosh they're in love they've
been dating for so long they're having a
bit that's what you do okay so for me
like the Tyler thing like there were so
many hints like there was the following
there was like the mom thing like there
was so much when it actually got
confirmation that they were dating I was
like not surprising like damn this is
crazy but I wasn't taken off-guard
with this baby thing like what I know
about Gigi in Zane's relationship is
that it's like really on and off or kind
of tumultuous like to me this is genuine
shock sudden shock note to me like just
because Gigi followed the cute guy from
The Bachelor does not mean she's
stepping out with him it so how is he's
staying at her house and making that
walk down that like iconic Street that
she lives on like going to the
Netherlands for her grandma's family
that was weird
no that was some crazy [ __ ] that was
crazier than this to me that will ever
be like that was on the level of Megan
and Harry of a Hallmark star and the
Prince totally and you know what's so
interesting is like where Tyler's at now
verse where he was at after the bachelor
you know yeah but he's still kind of a
tier above Bachelor life except that
because he's dating someone from the
bachelor world he's very much a bachelor
guy now yeah but he'll probably never go
on one of those shows like paradise I
think if he was offered the bachelor he
wouldn't take it I don't think we'll
really ever see him in like a
traditional bachelor setting ever again
yeah I would agree with that we'll see I
agree
well anyways I'm so happy for GG I'm so
happy for Rhonda I'm so excited to talk
about Beverly Hills cuz she did come up
in the episode that was so crazy that
was so random and like so wonderful when
she called her Yolanda Foster it's like
Yolanda Hadid
yeah crazy okay I think her and Erica
are still really good friends I think so
too
that was like a nice changeup when like
Yolanda brought her onto the show and
like Erica a lot of times like when the
women bring on a woman into the show
like it never ends well but that's like
one of the rare occasions where like
that meets you'll love and respect for
each other even though you'll want to
like faded from the show like not in the
most delightful way it really they
always stayed true to each other and I
love them yeah okay next story because
kendall Jenner has stepped out with the
most iconic tweet of all time because
people on Twitter was talking about her
dating life TMZ sports tweeted about the
story that she was with Devin Booker
taking a road trip and someone commented
a video like a three guys like throwing
a girl around and they're like NBA
players with Kendall Jenner and someone
replied to that video said maybe she's
passing them around and can no reply to
that tweet and said they act like I'm
not in full control of where I throw
this couch such a [ __ ] amazing
response first of all the phrase throw
this couch here for it and just like the
way people talk about like a women and
like just the fact that Kendall had to
see like it's just so vile like who the
[ __ ] speaks like that like no one would
say that I'm sorry to sound like Taylor
strip but like no one would say that if
it was you know Bradley Cooper dating a
million models like no one thinks twice
and this is the way they speak about her
so vulgar passing her around yeah I
agree and I'm glad she took control cuz
like that is the funniest [ __ ] tweet
all of her sisters trying to like can
you imagine I didn't know that she had
this kind of rhetoric in her and I'm so
absolutely here for it and I hope it is
true I hope she is dating that guy
because she's in full control of where
she throws a couch two things to say one
she was trending on Twitter all day like
I saw that tweet come up a million time
she was trending on Twitter all day so
like great day for Kris Jenner you know
it's been a slow news day went with the
kovat crisis and the second thing I want
to say is some information I found out
about Devin Booker is that his name the
NBA player is that there was a lot of
speculation that he dated Jordan Woods
like for a little while before the
Tristan Thompson thing so I'm on Twitter
right now and one of the replies to
Kendall's tweet is that
that Jeff of the guy who like obviously
just like said something crazy and his
friends are freaking out you know this I
know that is I love that Jeff and I just
like that's exactly how I feel right now
even you saying Jordan woods I'm like
I'm his friends you know yeah and now I
just wanted to follow up to that because
there's an article Jordan woods drags
Kendall Jenner and Shady tweet after
being spotted with her ex so Jordan
woods may have just thrown some subtle
shade at former friend kendall Jenner
over her new love interest our reality
star and model Jenner was spotted
hanging out with Devin Booker reports
claim the pair made an 8 hour journey
blah blah blah okay let me get to the
tee here's here's where it gets
interesting it turns out Booker used
today Jordan was who was famously
shunned by the kardashian-jenner 's
after the infamous Tristan Thompson
dating scandal Woods and Booker even
went on a double date with Kendall and
her ex-boyfriend Ben Simmons in 2018 TMZ
reports
it appears Jordan found humor in the
situation some of her eagle-eyed
followers spotted her tweeting haha good
morning followed by a separate tweet of
three trashcan emojis
soon after posting she deleted the
tweets hey girl don't even like really
Neiman like at least she stopped dating
at least she waited for you to stop
dating this guy before trying to I
thought with him that's not your mo
Jenny welcome
no he was okay right and also like
you're not friends anymore so she can
pee no what is she up to
she's such an enigma to me you know like
an interesting level of Fame where she
was never really actually famous for
anything other than being Kylie's friend
but then she literally was one of the
biggest news stories of like 2019 and I
just find her so interesting I wonder
like how she makes money I'm sure she
actually makes a lot of money I think
she does too like where she lives looks
really nice and she has so many
Instagram followers and brand deals and
I think she does really well so I'm
happy I think it worked out well for
everyone yeah and I think she comes from
a wealthy family
perhaps okay
next story some exciting content news
Netflix's the politician season 2
release date gets confer
really see it confirmed so this is
really exciting Netflix is serious a
politician which it was everything of
the sort if you haven't watched it yet
please go do had a brilliant response
when it was
back in 2019 and luckily the cast and
crew finished filming season two ahead
of the coronavirus lockdown speaking
about the upcoming series creator Ryan
Murphy confirmed it was being released
on the streaming service in June
chatting to Khalid er he said quote we
were lucky enough that we finished
filming and editing right before the
current virus thing happened we have
seven we have finished all of our
episodes he continued we have a great
second season I think we're trying to
figure out how we how do we mix them now
in the social distancing age I think we
figured it out it's going to come out in
the middle of June still season two I'm
really proud of it I loved what we came
up with Brad Falchuk Ian and Ian Brennan
and I yay that's so great finally like
someone taking note again I don't know
how many times have to say it the
society like there's and by the way
we've been saying this since like day
one of quarantine and it's been a long
time and I really still don't feel like
anyone is really taking advantage in
like the streaming wars of the fact that
like people are desperate for content
yeah I feel like Netflix is probably the
most but here's what I don't understand
and this society it's different because
they haven't filmed the episodes they
can't give it to it they just can't like
there's nothing that they can give us
but the politician is done drop it now
yeah like I'm sure that there's similar
shows in the similar position as the
politician that are filmed that are
edited like even if you think of two out
to handle it was filmed over a year ago
like they have content in the queue and
I don't know why in the queue we're not
getting what we need also in June
hopefully like we will be resuming some
semblance of normal life um it won't be
as dire then as it is now I got plans I
got trips like in June if because I'm
again out in June I'm getting out I'm
well it's May 5th don't days like today
it's monsoon season outside like I've
never been happier to be home and you
know I know I say like something
different every week but this week I'm
actually really enjoying quarantine like
I got new sheets you could see they're
from Brooklyn and they're so white and
fresh and I'm just like I'm feeling
happy which is a new feeling for me wow
that must be nice okay
ready for our next story speaking of
cute competitors Google's zoom rival
called meet is now free to customers
Google on Wednesday said it's making its
teleconference conferencing service
called Google meet free to customers the
move takes aim at zoom the rival video
chat service that's become a household
name during the stay at home Aris burned
by the corona virus previously meat was
only able available to paying customers
of G sweet Google's line of enterprise
apps that includes Gmail Drive and Doc's
until now anyone could join a meeting by
clicking on a link but creating a
meeting required a G's suite membership
so now they're making this available to
everyone they're hoping to become a
competitor of zoom and again I'm just
feeling like it's too little too late
like we're getting out in 16 days yeah I
also don't really work super like
corporately so I was not familiar with
like the landscape of these kind of
interfaces and now that I'm in
quarantine and I'm being forced like I
understand that zoom is like the best
thing but like when did soom become the
hottest thing like a not Google Hangouts
cuz the last time I was like an intern
in the corporate world like Google
Hangouts was the place to be no totally
and zoom was like the Skype of
conference sessions it's like no one's
like oh he's on it but everyone can get
on it if they need to but not everyone
has Google Hangouts Gmail but most
people that you confer with do I don't
know what happened to Google Hangouts
this seems like a missed opportunity for
them zoom really got their [ __ ] together
because not only do they do all the
meetings like they have all of the
little things that you can need like
even recording like how we do um you can
take your video like on and off you can
arrange all the faces in different ways
I gets great for podcasts great for
meetings like I don't know why people
would use something else at this point
like Zune gets it all done oh except
that zoom has like major data breach
issues and it's like not totally private
so hey FBI hey CIA can you get my legs
delivered can you get my migraine pills
delivered um yeah but then also I get
for like a work situation definitely
these platforms are the [ __ ] but like
ever since FaceTime allowed you to
FaceTime with more than one person like
that is truly the platform of all
platforms oh yeah for damn sure except
like even when we do our uh happy hours
we don't do them on FaceTime we do
zooom there's a little bit more like
yeah there's something more like we're
having a plan if we're using zoom and a
computer that's the exact difference
FaceTime is very spur-of-the-moment like
hey let's just invite Jackie to this
FaceTime where a zoom is like a plan
it's on the calendar it's scheduled out
um so they're both great and those are
the two platforms I happen to be using
the most
yes me too for sure I don't think I've
used anything else at this point well we
used Skype for dr. deborah birx and we
used a WebEx or something
Oh for that internal meeting that we
were so funny I remember yeah yeah that
was good time so it feels like forever
ago jack and i hosted some internal
meeting for like 50 people and it was so
funny like we literally should have
recorded it and sold it as a comedy
special we were being hilarious actually
where oh my god things that like never
happened so funny
science member it's annoying to talk
about inside jokes I think I have good
like corporate humor you know cuz you
rocked it for so long
totally okay our fifth and final story
very sweet story
Mattel pays tribute to frontline workers
with special edition collectible action
figures from New York City's Blue Angels
and Thunderbirds fly by to local parades
people around the world are finding
unique ways to say thank you to those
working on the front line of the corona
virus pandemic business is too no matter
how big or how small are doing their
part to assist those most impacted by
the crisis most recently Mattel showed
its support for heroes with a new set of
collectible action figures profits of
which will go directly to the
communities who need it most the hashtag
Thank You Heroes collection which
launched on Wednesday features 16 action
figures represented by doctor's delivery
drivers nurses and EMTs five little
people community champions are also
included in the collection which
features a grocery store worker doctor
nurse medical technician and delivery
driver
so yeah it's cute this is a trend I'm
seeing a lot with Corona and I'm trying
not to be negative because I understand
that everyone's doing their part but
like to me I think like donating a
portion of your proceeds is like so
shady because if you think
like you're really only doing it because
you made money and it's like that's not
real charity like reaction also donating
a portion of your proceeds like while
yes it's it's semi altruistic it's also
a marketing campaign and so then you're
using like I understood so many so many
companies are doing it and like I think
it's overall it's good because it ends
up in a good place but like it just
doesn't sit totally well with me when it
comes to like people have said like we
should do that and I'm like I'm happy to
donate but I don't like using something
like that as like a marketing thing yeah
we have this conversation with our merch
because we were like should we do like a
portion of the proceeds and it's like
Jackie and I have both on social media
but also privately like donated to
things that are important like for me
it's like I would rather instead of
buying a Mattel doll it's like I would
rather buy a meal for a nurse because I
don't know where that portion of the
doll which organization that's going to
and then who that organization is giving
the money to like I don't know it's just
something about this I've seen it a lot
with like influencers of muggers - like
doing their launches or or you know
selling whatever like portion of the
proceeds and to me it's like it just
doesn't seem genuine and it's like I
don't know where that money's going
that's what so like just heart like
scary okay I feel like we actually we
did we both disagree with it but for
different reasons and I also feel like
with some influencers they're very
transparent about where the money is
going and they'll show you you know it's
kind of like a Bethany thing
it's a Elle Bernstein thing like she's
doing a lot of good [ __ ] so it's not
always like that but I just feel like
people are like oh I feel weird about
launching something right now how do I
make it about coronavirus I mean donate
a portion of the proceeds and then it's
like you just do it to sort of tie in to
this tragedy and it just like donate or
don't donate but like I'm not buying
your sweat suit because I think I'm
doing something good for the world yeah
there's just something like inherently
tacky about it yeah I I like it it's not
it's it's no but it's not considered
tacky like to a consumer it's not
actually put into that position of like
I never thought anything of it until we
were doing like a merge luncheon I think
some people had suggested and I was like
oh that's a nice idea I mean they think
it through and then it's like then we're
just
using this as a way to get people to buy
our merch I just don't like that yeah no
I completely agree and I was if we
wanted to
I've right I'd rather donate and I don't
need to tell you all about it like agree
that and I agreed yeah um well I'm glad
that I'm glad what was the story the
Barbies like I just I'm done right and
so sorry what I was gonna say about that
it's like a huge company like Mattel
like just fork over 20 grand stop with
this nobody really needs an action
figure
about someone bagging groceries it's
like it's not really anything like but I
see that you want to do good like put
your money where your mouth is just
write a [ __ ] check don't make me pay
you so that you'll pay yeah yep yep okay
here you Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills another fabulous episode like
nothing even happened I just like one
invited to the next dinner party at
Kyle's house because she is so fabulous
her house is so fabulous
she always had she always has drinks
like her whole dinner parties are always
revolved around the bar and like I
really love and appreciate that and she
invited the lady sitter I'm like I just
wanted to be there so badly oh my god
no I that was like I did not want to be
there that was weirdly the strangest
dinner party like so awkward and boring
especially considering all the women
went into the party like on such great
terms so happy to see each other like
can't wait we're all gonna drink and
then like it was one of like the worst
dinner parties I've ever seen oh I just
guess you're right about that but like
I'm just craving a dinner party I think
that part of where they went wrong and
you're right like everyone showed up for
the most part besides her sudden and
teddy like however all the ladies are
like really driving really well and I
think where they went wrong was with the
seating where they literally do like a
Makita boys and girls and it was like a
separating dinner where like if you were
in a cast member you weren't allowed to
talk and they like played these games
whereas like if they had just had a real
dinner and filmed it I think it would
have been more interesting no honestly
where they went wrong I said son and
Teddy the only two people who are like
kind of miffed with one another
shouldn't be sitting next to each other
and then we have to go around and talk
about the person next to us it's like
they set them up for that disaster
calamity and also like I love a game
where we like talk about you know the
accolades of the person next with
someone's birthday but it was just like
it was really it was a strange game
especially to be played amongst
most of the women who are very close so
you're really only doing it for Sutton
and don't worry she'll say something
when she has something to say she is
just like really bothering me so much
and I'm really like shook that Kyle is
kind of gravitating towards her and Kyle
explained in her testimonial that like
she just kind of feels bad for Sutton
cuz Sutton is kind of acting like she's
intimidated by this group but it's like
I didn't really get that at all
I mean Teddy and Kyle are so close I was
just kind of shocked that she didn't
stand up to Sutton more like on behalf
of her friend so I didn't feel like
Sutton did anything wrong in this
episode honestly okay I think that she
was just being weird and nothing that
could like really put her in the wrong
until she said and then you were
pregnant oh god like that was just so
rude like so rude not not anything other
than just like hurtful and honestly I
understood Teddy's hormonal and then
like someone's making fun of her someone
she's been butting heads with and then
they say something like really so [ __ ]
up like I thought that was where she
lost me like I thought Teddy was being a
drama queen until she said that um I
don't think he was so [ __ ] up I
understood why Teddy got emotional
because she's probably feeling all these
things and and that's fine and I might
have gotten emotional too but then like
as a viewer I don't think what she said
was [ __ ] up
every woman in that room like has been
pregnant like it's not a slight but it's
like when you're pregnant like if you're
boring before when you're pregnant like
you might be more boring cuz most like
you can't drink like I didn't think she
was saying it in any like she's been
pregnant I don't think she was just
speaking from her experience probably I
didn't I didn't like I wasn't the best
thing anyone's ever said but I didn't
think it was like I thought she was just
being funny about how she thought Teddy
was gonna be so boring and she was just
going in on that side until she was
gonna be like but you're actually this
that in the other yeah and what was
interesting was that when Teddy got up
she wasn't really angry about the the
pregnant thing she was angry about like
I'm trying to be chillin it's like Teddy
kind of entered this season like having
an identity crisis where it's like she's
trying to take feedback from viewers
about like chilling out but she's just
not a chill person I'm like that's okay
but she keeps trying to be something
she's not and I think it's creating more
problems for her I totally agree like
you're not a chill person you're never
going to be
that's like so many people are like you
high-strung you know like anagram one
like and that just be yourself totally I
like so I thought it was what I took
umbrage with it didn't really seem like
Teddy did because she was already so
upset and then she got up and she was
crying about being chill I don't know
yeah I think it's just like a lot I
think also like this thing with the text
message I get obviously didn't go over
well with anyone's it was the strangest
text ever and I think she's just
emotional and pregnant like I could see
that happening to me also when it feels
like everyone's going around like I
could see everyone's going around the
table having no issue saying something
nice method person next time and then
you get the person who's supposed to say
something nice about you it's like it's
just so backhanded because you guys are
actually there's nothing nice to say and
like you're ready emotional pregnant and
like yeah I'm gonna start crying so
their interaction was awkward but I
think what was even more awkward was
Denise trying to say something nice
about Sutton because they obviously
don't know each other they're incredibly
different and Denise is just like really
lovely and not catty and rude like that
so she was just like I just think you're
lovely like it was yeah weird yes she
just like used all nice words it down to
earth like blah blah blah like not true
but okay like the moment between Erica
and to read was like maybe one of the
best moments ever because they like came
out so rough and now I like them both so
much individually and the fact that
they're like seeing one another is so
fabulous so fabulous and like they're so
like to the untrained eye they're so
similar but once you get to know them
they are so different
totally but we did skit to see like a
little bit more of Therese house I'm
just like so invested and concerned
about like the finances but we were
talking about last week how much she has
a nice house Blake we don't know where
it is but it turns out she lives right
around the corner from Kyle and Mauricio
and they're obviously doing really
really well they definitely live in a
fancy area so I think it's safe to
assume that to read and piqué like moved
into a swanky neighborhood and a swanky
six million dollar house so by the looks
of it it looks like things might be okay
and what I don't understand is like if
they don't have the money in the bank
like how do you get a six million dollar
house and like if it's possible just
like let me know but like you have or no
when she goes to the store and buys
everything on the Chanel rack and
gives her credit card but she doesn't
have the money in the bank how does the
credit card go through like that's what
I don't understand if this is where
Doreen sometimes and her wardrobe which
is fabulous gives me a little bit of a
Leeanne Locken vibe because Leeanne
Locken
on I just need to read has better style
so at first I didn't notice
like Leeanne Locken wore a Chanel belt
Chanel jewelry Chanel bag Chanel shoes
every single episode a different Chanel
jewelry Chanel bag it was crazy and if
you know a lot about her you know she
was not the wealthiest on the show and
she talked about a lot about her wedding
like she struggled financially so it
made no sense
it was so obvious it's like you're
living this life but then you're showing
up in the different Gucci belts every
day like I did it makes sense and I
think now I'm like looking back on the
jury thing it's like she and I don't
know what the answer was with Leeanne
like maybe she was borrowing from like a
rich friend but dorita is maybe giving
me a similar vibe okay I hear what
you're saying but I totally disagree
because with Leeanne like it was like
she was also high fashion but then would
talk about how she that didn't have
money for her wedding you know nothing
else added up but then she's stepping
out and I really do think she was
borrowing from maybe friends are like
boutiques or whatever but with her eat
like every sink since season one she's
been stepping out like with this season
everything like the best the creme de la
creme but like her house matches her
wardrobe you know PK's job matches her
wardrobe that's true there's a level of
consistency that Leeanne Locken lacked
yeah I think it's so different I think
honestly it's like iftar eat is not the
real deal it's like on a much bigger
scale I don't think that Leeanne like
was embezzling yeah I don't think she's
like spending money that she hasn't had
like I think it's two different
situations I just think it's so crazy
and you really can't hide like she's
just so exposed right now and I'm just
so concerned either it's like totally
untrue or 100 percent sure like there's
no in-between here but I don't know how
they've been on TV now like four four
five seasons and like the government
doesn't look into them or something so
I'm just like I need to just believe
that they're there by the book
I can't I just I don't want to be seen
like an episode of American greed about
them their house is so nice I love this
new house but it's like everything jury
does is just like even her Versace look
in her confessional like she even has a
Versace scrunchie like she doesn't skimp
out on anything oh my god Erica going in
on Sutton's looks is one of my favorite
things happening on Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills Suns just so I'm not just
like ready to it yeah I actually really
liked sudden stress at the dinner party
I thought it was really cute
um but yet they they're not vibing area
but I think that's an underlying current
what's with Sutton's boyfriend he's so
mysterious he doesn't talk oh yeah
everyone was like showing up with guys I
said and then lady sitter was sitting
next to this guy and I'm like he looks
so familiar who is that who is that and
that was it oh it's Edwin different no
also the seating was so weird no one was
sitting next to their husband except in
terms of husbands like the MVP of this
entire series is Mauricio Umansky I love
how he used to be like so involved in
drama like having Kyle's back like
running around town with Ken Vanderpump
now he just like smokes pot before every
event and he's just so happy and I love
him yeah we need to talk about what was
actually the craziest scene at the
dinner party was Erin and Denise and
Erin talking about what he does for a
living and like first of all Kyle asking
that question like out of absolutely
nowhere like nobody asks nobody cared so
maybe she knew that there was something
there um and him talking about like this
new medicine and technology and how like
the government is chiness like you know
he's obviously and I don't it's not
nothing's obvious we've all had cancer
nothing about what he said was obvious
that was just friend yeah that was
really really crazy but I don't feel
like Denise has it like is not
delusional so if she thinks people are
following her like people might be
following her whether I believe that
people are following her I just don't
think it's the government I think it's
losers Oh or maybe it's like Charlie
Sheen's puppy I yeah honestly the whole
conversation was
strange but I really wanted to hear more
from Lisa Rinna because it sounded like
she knew more she's like her husband is
really into something energy and she
knows a lot about it and I just wanted
to hear what she was talking about but
honestly the whole conversation went
completely over my head no it was so
crazy that was like hilarious but so
weird it was really weird strange yeah
um okay what else I think that was it
things I mean Sutton I just want I just
have to talk more [ __ ] about her she
bothers me so much I'm her like
complaining about not having place cards
and like being sofa clamped about
manners and then like bringing a bottle
of fireball like that's those two just
don't match like I understood internally
like what she was feeling about place
cards and where to sit like that's
exactly how I feel that I didn't her
party but I've never said it and made it
the host's problem and made everyone
play musical chairs to find me an
appropriate seat that actually turned
out to be the worst possible seat for me
yeah and like I understood why she new
to the group would want an assigned seat
it just makes it easier it's less it
removes that level of weirdness but it's
like to just be so condescending like
putting your nose down there's another
dinner party without place settings like
shut the [ __ ] up
yeah thank you okay well I feel like
that's that's it it was a really crazy
episode I'm excited for tonight yeah
brownie and Kardashians um looks so good
I know I'm so excited oh my god so last
night I started watching because I
finished manhunt Unabomber and if you
were into Waco and you're like looking
for more nineties stories because you
missed all of the night these like me I
would totally watch it like it's not as
you know cinematically stellar as Waco
but it's still like such a crazy story
um so that was really enjoyable and then
I was looking for like more content I
wound up watching like some Discovery
Channel America in color where they like
it's the series where like each episode
is like a decade starting with in 20s
but they use all old footage that
they've colorized so it's actually kind
of cool to watch and they just explain
like what was going down and there was
some crazy [ __ ] happening that I've
never heard about like this major
hurricane in Miami in the twenties I
just was
bigger than Katrina but like why would I
know about that anyways it was kind of
interesting but I don't think I'm gonna
go back to X now I'm up to the 1950s and
just I am I'm watching season seven of
RuPaul's Drag Race and it's like the
talent for the biggest judges is so
supreme like now they had Ariana Grande
they weirdly had Jessica Alba's she was
like so not the right person to be dish
was just promoting honest products and
like each time each week there's a
challenge and like someone wins and when
it's the guest like you'll win something
may be directly correlated to the guest
so the person who won the challenge when
a year's supply of honest company
products like what the fuck'd is a drug
we need on this company Fox or a baby
stuff no I think it's both it's like I
think that's how it started but now it's
just like not clean Beauty it it was
just weird like she literally only went
on the show to promote our products and
the person who won was like some people
win like trips to Hawaii like thousands
of dollars in gowns or drag jewelry
you're like thank you I think I'm gonna
watch Jack Ryan snitch show me to watch
it that sounds like something you might
like I don't know I never like I kind of
like military stuff but I don't like
fictional stuff especially when it comes
to like war like there's enough war
stories it's got a true one so true I
think that's all we got for you guys so
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go where we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found set
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio I
already owe cashbox all the places where
ever you listen to podcast find us the
morning tell us leave a five star view
about our beautiful settings Barbie are
we love you guys so much Peele see you
tomorrow for Friday bye